so m good evening mariam and welcome to
strasbourg the european deputies left
brussels not to visit the
traditional christmas market in strasbourg
but for their last
plenary session of the year
as for us we ventured
on the ice to present to you
the  next year's agenda
and to start we are going to
cross the Atlantic
and yes marianne often comes the devil
and so detail is here the detail is
the dispute investors are they
wrong
what is it  what that means in fact
the idea is laudable protect
foreign investors who want to
invest on both sides of
the atlantic
only here some member states
see it as a danger for their technical national sovereignty
well no marianne jean claude  juncker
is neither a magician nor santa claus
he did propose a plan of 315
billion euros to boost employment and
growth proposals made during the
month of november 2014 the
european commission proposes a little over 20
billion the rest is supposed to come from
the popular sector a possible tool would
of course be the european investment bank
which could finance
some but not all of course to follow
so
is what you remember we  must
lead gurs then she lacked what of
between google the european union it's a
bit but jude cat and mouse the
cat is the european union the mouse
is google
then it's not  the first time that
the story has posed a problem between the two
an antitrust case is
still before the courts for
the moment at the heart of the digital agenda
there is an idea to make the
european union the world leader in the sector
which could be very interesting
some specialists are already saying that
this could represent 500
billion euros injected into the european union
the united states china europe have all
promised to reduce their
greenhouse gas emissions l  he union wants a drop
of 40% by 2030
but the other world powers
will follow to find out it will be necessary to
wait for the betting conference on the
climate the magic formula to fight
against immigration would be
solidarity by the end of 2015 a  new
report is supposed to provide solutions
to help the member states most
affected and save lives
the six pack and the tupac will also be
overhauled in 2015 these tools should
ensure that European countries
achieve their
tax objectives
and well me too mariam  I am going to
take the height to talk to you about the
rights of passengers
they will again be at the leg in the
European parliament in 2015 better
compensation less
waiting times more transport of
goods which are there
some of the points which will be at  the agenda
meeting in February plays a
vote is planned to retain
oh
that's all for today and
that's all for this year  e vermeil
crisis is not over and until then
be well